what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
there is a comic book where Han Solo and
Chewbacca fight zombies yes there is I
better be seeing some likes I'm gonna be
seeing it so comments ladies and
gentlemen this comic book is actually
really cool it's sure there's only like
you know 15 or so pages but it's still
pretty cool in and of itself now this
comes to us as part of Star Wars tales
now for those of you guys who are
familiar with Star Wars you know about
like Star Wars and comics things like
that bear with me because like every
video is somebody's first video and we
have to treat it that way so if you're
just now stumbling on to my channel if
you've never really read Star Wars or
don't really know much about Star Wars
in comic book form and a lot of other
media when Disney bought the slot wars
franchise it basically killed off the
expanded universe now I've explained
that in other videos which you'll find
down in the description in fact you'll
just find the whole playlist of videos
down in the description we talked about
Star Wars stuff but one of the aspects
of the expanded universe was the comics
under Dark Horse and dark horse had been
publishing Star Wars cover book material
for quite some time they had like the
origin of the Sith which I'll actually
cover here on this channel
they had miscellaneous stories here and
there they had a lot of just you know
backstory to the Star Wars universe and
some of the things they win in the
future and some stories that covered
events that were going on at the same
time as the movies but when Disney
bought the spot Wars franchise they
effectively killed off all that stuff
and they handed the comics back over to
Marvel and Marvel began printing
official Star Wars material so that's
where like the current Star Wars run
from Jason Aaron comes from that's where
the Darth Vader comic book run right now
from Karen Gillan comes from all that's
considered to be Canon or official
content now with regards to Star Wars
tales these were really written by a
multitude of authors there were releases
trades and it was just a series of small
short stories relating to the Star Wars
universe the kicker to all this is that
none of these were in continuity none of
these were considered official even by
dark forces standards they were just
kind of out there it was like what if
stories you know what if han Solo and
Chewbacca fought zombies and so you know
we weren't necessarily given the most
in-depth story ever but at the very
least it was just as on to be comedic
sometimes he was designed to be serious
it was always designed to be outside
of the existing Star Wars continuity
with regards to the comics the movies
the whole nine yards so what this does
is it initially picks up with Han Solo
and Chewbacca coming back from some
mission that's never really explained to
us or some quests never really explained
to us but their issues are they're
currently running out of fuel and so
because of this they actually end up
finding a world that's not been charted
on the Republic mats and they end up
landing here now the funny thing about
this is that in the realm of Star Wars
there are a lot of worlds that are not
charted by the Republic sometimes it's
because of the fact that they're removed
from the Republic maps sometimes is
because Republic just didn't chart that
far out especially when we get into the
unknown realm of star wars but the idea
here is that this world not being
charted leaves a lot of things ambiguous
in terms of what it is you know the
people who are there a lot of this is
likely due to the fact though that these
individuals on this planet have not
achieved interstellar travel meaning
they have not been able to travel from
one planet to the next and in fact we've
learned a little more about this here in
a second but when han Solo and Chewbacca
land on this planet Han Solo is kind of
like hey this is weird like this plan is
basically empty and have cities and
stuff so people were here at one point
but no one's here now like I don't
understand why now as soon as they get
out of the Millennium Falcon and they
actually step onto the surface there's a
couple things they notice first of
course there's a ton of fog but they
actually hear a crash so that I would
you keep that in the back of your head
because that'll be important going
forward but they also hear like these
weird mysterious voices you know saying
help us so on and so forth now in true
Chewbacca fashion Han Solo is like hey
there's these weird disembodied voices
that sound really creepy and strange you
know let's go investigate Chewbacca and
choo he's like nope and he goes right
back into the ship he knope's right out
of there and runs into the ship and so
Han Solo's just kind of left to
investigate now the cool thing about
this with regards to Steve Niles who's
currently writing it is I think he does
a really good job of like capturing the
mannerisms of Han Solo in the sense that
Han Solo when he first showed up in Star
Wars a new hope you know very much had
like this devil-may-care attitude and
the sense that he was kind of like Oh
rogue you know he was a bad guy or not
really bad guy he was like I guess a bad
guy in this sense of like a bad boy kind
of thing you know he was it lived his
life on the fringes of space you know
making money as best he could and
smuggling all that kind of cool stuff
you know a scoundrel type you know view
of the world but the idea here is that
as time progressed his character of
course began to change to where he
became more involved with Republic and
eventually became a major rallying point
behind various Republic soldiers while
they were implementing these campaign
to eliminate the remnants of the empire
following the events of Empire Strikes
Back and so because of this you know we
really get this like early days han Solo
where it's not necessarily that he's a
bad boy but he's kind of in that
transitionary phase where he's going
from being a bad boy to basically being
a grown-up to being a respectable human
being and so because of this once he
arrives he's immediately set upon by all
these monsters you know by all these
zombies and he definitely can to try to
hold them off but of course calling for
to Baca eventually Chewie steps in this
is what I say we get these great man you
isms of Han Solo because you know when
she eat fights off a bunch of these
monsters and sends them on their way
your Han Solo says hey man almost had
them like why did you step in almost had
these guys again you know this is just
kind of one of those little funny things
that goes into the into the evolution of
his character but the idea here is you
know for for Han Solo he takes the
stance that hey if we just kind of wait
him out you know if we just chill we
wait until the morning then eventually
they'll go away whether it's because
there is kind of wandering around or
whether it because they'll lose interest
or something like that now Steve Niles
doesn't really give us a reason why they
would do this and this is one of the
crazy things because now it's kind of
relies on us as the reader to take
certain liberties in terms of how
zombies exist right I mean in the
traditional sense of zombies we always
take them as like these mindless
creatures with extremely low levels of
intelligence and their interest in an
object is confined only so long as
there's nothing else to distract them
but as soon as something else distracts
them notice go wandering off we see that
a lot in The Walking Dead you know in
Walking Dead you have zombies that are
walking around you know and then of
course when like Rick Grimes first met
Abraham for example you know Rick Grimes
fired off a gun and Abraham said don't
do that because if you do one zombie
somewhere will hear it don't start
walking this direction another zombie
will see them and start following they
start passing through towns and suddenly
you've got a horde of zombies 10,000
strong heading in your direction so he's
like you know don't do something like
that but you know Niles kind of relies
on us to sort of take these elements of
how he perceives ahhm be a man with
regards to this story and so well a lot
of this stuff is left out it's really
kind of coming on us to fill in the gaps
to a degree but again as they disembark
the ship you know going into the next
morning they end up running into a woman
now this woman basically gives us the
whole story here now she's not the only
inhabitant you know her in her child and
not the only people here but she gives
us this story now this is a little
lackluster it really is just kind of
Steve Niles you know throwing it out
there and I'll explain why here in a
second but what she says
is that their people were on the cusp of
interstellar travel again the reason why
they hadn't been charted by the Republic
was because there was no reason for the
Republic to take notice of them but you
know they had been toying with the idea
of interstellar travel and had been
looking at to basically you know escape
their own planet for the purposes of
exploring the known galaxies and all the
different treasures and so on that it
has to offer but the problem with this
was that as they were preparing for it
they basically built this giant monolith
this giant you know interplanetary Ark
that would have allowed them to travel
from one side of the only galaxy to the
other now the reason why this is
important is because within star wars
you have hyperdrive you know which
basically allow people to achieve
faster-than-light travel it's quite
literally just folding space in on
itself and then traveling from one base
to the next almost instantaneously these
people didn't have that kind of
technology where they did have though
was the ability to construct an ark that
would allow them to pass through and end
up on the other side the reason why I
say the technology was in advance is
because with the Ark it's really just
you know people paying their money and
taking their chances they have no idea
where they'll end up they just you know
walk through the Ark and then hopefully
they end up on a planet where they don't
die but with a hyperdrive this allows
for mobile faster than light travel you
can literally traverse the galaxy you
know while you're flying around but it
also allows for a much more precise
targeting system in the sense that you
can basically figure out exactly where
you want to go allowing for the fact
that the navigational charts are correct
that they're accurate but the fact
remains here that this one basically
says look you know when this construct
was launched when this Ark was created
you know they took off into space but
then they started crashing back down
into the planet they basically crashed
into the planet itself and they all died
in the process and so the result is that
all these members of the crew basically
reanimate at the same time every night
when they originally died and they're
just doomed to sort of haunt the planet
haunt that area and so no han Solo says
ok look and this is the cajon if they're
effectively just doomed to repeat their
own death over and over and over again
and is because of the fact that when
they crash back down into the planet
they couldn't navigate through the mist
and hit the ground then maybe we can fix
that problem for them and so this is
cool because this is you know
intelligent Han Solo this is Han Solo
being pretty deductive and so what he
ends up doing is he actually ends up
grabbing these little shards of light
and basically places them around to
create this landing pad you know there's
this sort of ad hoc landing pad and what
this does is it allows this ship that
you know I guess this ghostly ship that
would normally crash every
to actually know where it's supposed to
go to know where the ground is and then
land effectively and so what this is is
it seems like Han Solo is basically
ending this cycle of constantly dying
but in truth we actually learned that's
not the case now the way we learn this
is hilarious what happens is when this
ship lands and these ghosts basically
depart and they begin to you know move
around and go home so to speak in a
sense that they can basically transition
to the afterlife
ah this woman says hey look you know we
really appreciate your help
thanks for putting these lights down
because now they'll constantly repeat
this process but they'll basically land
and they won't haunt anymore like they
won't be you know these monsters running
around trying to kill people but Han
Solo was like hey I'm not gonna leave
these lights here like we gotta use them
now I think it would have been hilarious
if he had actually taken and just been
like hate none enough like this is only
temporary
like we just did this so long so that we
can refuel but as soon as we bail out
like we're taking those lights with us
you know so no good luck of course
Chewie Bishop we talked him out of that
and says no no no no you can do that
you know you got to help these people
you got to be kind that kind of thing
but again this is why it's all
transitionary you know because this is
Han Solo going from being this rogue
this scoundrel to becoming a good guy
you know becoming the kind of Han saw of
the world so used to again it's outside
of the existing continuity but it's very
least it's good to see his character
evolved but that's pretty much the story
I mean it's like I said it's not a great
big huge long drawn-out thing it's
pretty straightforward
but I thought it'd be fun I thought it'd
be fun to run over the story of how Han
Solo and Chewbacca fought against like
zombie ghosts or whatever it is so
anyway I think I knew here to commerce
explain make sure you guys to the
subscribe button to become part of the
Rob port if you guys want to see more
Star Wars material this week make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]
you